wanted to talk a little bit about two
brands I've been fortunate to be
involved in the building of two brands
since 97 the first one was a W Hotels
brand which I was involved in in 97 and
99 and then red envelope the gift brand
from 99 to current W was the first new
brand that was built in the hotel
industry in at that time in 17 years the
last one was Hyatt and I was hired by
Barry Stern like who's the chairman and
CEO of Starwood Hotels & Resorts to
create the W which was at that time no
we didn't know was gonna call the W the
interest my interest and Barry's
interest was in giving American
customers who were spending a lot of
time traveling for business the ability
to have a hotel that was very
comfortable and had a lot of style but
still served all the needs of a business
traveler which meant that it would have
conference rooms internet access all of
the things that were important to
business travelers that the boutique
hotels that were doing a great job in
style and comfort weren't serving so
Barry had a real interest in what Ian
Schrager was doing in New York loved the
whole spirit of the boutique hotel but
purchased shortly after I got there
Weston and Sheridan and became one of
the largest hotel companies and realized
that there was a real need for a
business hotel so my job in developing W
was to bring together the best of the
style and comfort and the boutique
hotels with all of the business services
in a business hotel the two years I was
there we designed and built the first
ten hotels for W I think there's now
getting there getting close to 35 so
they've grown a lot since I left in 99 I
joined a tiny little comm that was doing
a million dollars a year and was when I
found out when I got there was out of
money so that was my first job was to
raise money to keep it alive and it was
an interesting project in a very
crazy time in building the gift brand
although it was a gift brand at night
nine-one-one gifts was really focused on
lowering gifts and really wasn't working
very well so it really became a start
over from scratch brand because we
changed everything from the name to the
positioning to bringing some money in
the company so we could start to market
it and first of all let me let me
apologize I just read my bio and it says
that galaxy deserts is just under a
hundred million dollars in sales
it should say well under 100 million
dollars and also in advance if I if I
stutter a few times I'm having
flashbacks right next door is we're in
the spring of 1990 professor Van Horn
nailed me in corporate finance so I
bought I I bought a little company right
out of Stanford in 91 called the
Cheesecake lady which was a couple
hundred thousand dollar bakery with with
a great product and no sales force and
no computers in the middle of nowhere
and I bought that with money I raised
mostly from my classmates we got real
jobs here and I grew that and paid off
the debt for a few years and in 1998
merged it with a friend of Mines bakery
to form galaxies desserts and we had an
idea that we could be the leading
company and individual gourmet desserts
and so we decided to try and build a
brand around that we went out we raised
a million dollars that first year bought
equipment started booming a management
team did things like build a monster
trade show booth that we couldn't afford
to try and build some trade awareness
and started growing and we've been
helped the last few years we we've been
on Oprah a couple times and we're
working towards being brands I don't
know but the first time we were on Oprah
it was just our product which was great
for sales but she she did mention our
name or my partner's name who's the chef
and then this year we were just on her
favorite things show November she
mentioned his name
so we're partially brand
so we're on run our way with that we we
sell to the retail trade Whole Foods
Wild Oats and erotic goes high in stores
like that as well as mainstream grocers
like Kroger and Safeway and I was just
talking to Peter here and about our new
launch of our low-carb desserts as we
are not afraid to jump on any trend
hopefully hopefully it'll last a little
that our low-fat cheese cake did a few
years ago that was really bad and
looking forward to talking to you about
how we've tried to build the brand I
want to say first of all Jim this is a
bad panel for a guy on the Afghan diet
to be on here between desserts chocolate
and beer and I'm not and I'm not trendy
enough to walk into W Hotel I'm not
skinny enough I have to so I I'm really
out of place on this I really feel that
way about there's a wonderful hotels all
that diversity there is a place for fat
bald guy
I spent my professional career building
brands and advertising I spent 20 years
with the coca-cola company ran marketing
the United States ran the wine marketing
for the company we were in a wine
business sterling vineyards and others
introduced Diet Coke in 50 countries
around the world I was the first head of
global marketing with the coca-cola
company and introduced a campaign called
always Coca Cola using a Hollywood
talent agent named Michael Ovitz I spent
eight years with coke when we owned
Columbia Pictures president marketing
and distribution and I had to introduce
a brand about every three weeks Tootsie
or Gandhi or stand by Mia which is a
really an interesting to try to build a
brand over over a weekend but I do feel
I have some knowledge on that I now
teach across the bay at at the Haas
School UC Berkeley I've been there for
10 years but I'm coming here in the
spring quarter and those of you are
students please marketing 392 brands and
marketing strategy moi is gonna be
teaching that I'm anxious to to see you
there the power of a brand I will tell
you I the Stanford brand I have 14 guest
lecturers coming the head of marketing
of General Motors American Airlines
while Kobe a bank the power of this
brand look at my syllabus on the on
coursework it's amazing how they're all
willing to come to to Palo Alto so we'll
talk a little about that in the in the
392 course that's my background my name
is Pete Schlossberg and I'm just a
homebrewer I got dirt under my
fingernails I came to the valley 25
years ago worked in high-tech I worked
for a company called Rome which became
part of IBM which became part of Siemens
but in the course of that it turned my
home brewing' into a homebrew club at
Rome and then in 1986 a friend of mine
and I started Pete's Brewing Company we
had the beer company for 13 years we
became a public company got to about 70
million in revenue and actually produced
a billion bottles of beer a billion
bottles of beer on the wall and then we
sold it in 1998 and I spent two years
with the acquiring company then I got
involved with a non profit for a couple
years but had the itch to do something
again and on a trip to Belgium several
trips to belch
meet Belgium Brewers you couldn't help
but find incredible chocolate in Belgium
did some research and found out that in
general chocolate in Europe was just far
superior to chocolate the United States
and the analog to the beer industry was
quite striking in that
Bud Miller and Coors got bigger and
bigger by making blander and Billy under
of products that opened the door for us
to produce full flavored beer and the
idea came let's try to produce an
all-american high quality premium
world-class chocolate bar company and
actually got to work with several second
years that Stanford two years ago they
helped me on a business plan and
identified that sure enough in the world
of chocolate even though the chocolate
being about a 15 billion dollar a year
industry is flat in revenue the premium
segment is just starting to take off
similar to the way craft beer took off
in the mid 80s so where our bet is that
we can make a unique set of premium
chocolate bars with a fun attitude the
whole attitude with the beer company was
produce a world-class product but have
fun with it we're trying to replicate
that in the world of beer so sorry to be
the only one doing this but I actually
brought samples will passes will pass
this around what I'm passing around is
sort of like my bridge back to the beer
business one of our products we call
multi Mis Maximus it's a real Brewers
malt and a malt crunchy and a darker
milk chocolate 36% cacao so we jokingly
call it a multiple on steroids and today
is a good day for both talking about
business and talking about beer I was a
beer judge this morning in San Francisco
judging barley wines so I feel in great
shape now to talk about whatever Hillary
you're sitting so close to me why don't
we start here you had two brands that
you were involved in so I thought maybe
we'd talk first a little bit just about
red envelope say this is kind of a you
know kind of a crazy time a cluttered
space and so on what were some of the
brand marketing techniques that you used
to help create that brand and get it to
stand out well it was an interesting
time I think one of the challenging
parts of development the red envelope
brand was in the.com
there was this interest in building a
brand as fast as possible and there was
a lot of money in the market so it was
we raised our first round of funding in
the summer of 99 and we're pretty much
asked to go spend it as quickly as
possible
and to build a brand very quickly I it
was it was a crazy time and a lot of the
peers of mine who are also running
dot-com companies were taking you know a
lot of millions of dollars and running
Super Bowl ads I think you you know saw
the hose and and we're sort of going
into the one-shot big moment marketing
campaigns to try to build their brand
our feeling was that red envelope needed
to become more than just calm brand I
thought that being online was a great
place to start the brand but that
ultimately to be a great specialty
retail brand it needed to be anywhere
the customer wanted it to be in that
long-term we launched a catalog shortly
after we launched our site and long-term
I believe that we will have stores and
have a comprehensive brand and so we
looked at at the marketing opportunities
differently than most of our our peer
group companies we didn't look at it as
being as quite as much of a rush to
build a brand overnight and thought
about it a little hopeful more more
thoughtfully we also looked for areas
where we could market our brand where
all the other coms weren't which was
sort of hard because they were
everywhere the one place that they
weren't was in lifestyle magazines that
we thought was important and targeting
our customer and so we ran full-page ads
in The New Yorker in Style magazine
Oprah's magazine many magazines were
both fashion home lifestyle magazines
and that was a surprisingly uncrowded
space it also was a lot cheaper than
television advertising which is what a
lot of the companies were doing we
avoided radio because radio was really
crowded we avoided TV obviously because
it was expensive and crowded and we
really focused on on the lifestyle
magazine
primarily as well as our marketing
programs we had with the major portals
online and I think that you know even
today people talk about the magazine ads
they remember them although they're now
2 years old I think it really helped
position the brand in a unique way
during our very crowd at the time mm-hmm
well first thing is we were two very
small brands which certainly limited the
challenges as there was large parts of
the country that had never heard of
either of us that's good news in the bad
news what we did is we we communicated
the hell out of everyone customers
vendors for about a year we used all
three names we said we officially said
Galaxie deserves home with Paris
delights in the cheesecake lady it was
on our our phone system was on our
letterhead it was on our packaging so
that lasted for about a year and then we
transition into a new logo and drop drop
the drop the other names so it was a
combination of of just massive
communication PR and we really we
focused on the trade we didn't have
enough presence to be recognizable
consumer brand so a trade shows and in a
little bit of trade advertising and any
editorial coverage we could get through
our PR people we told the story and we
tried to get the name galaxy out there
as much as we as we could so there was
there's some confusion
there's always confusion with change and
I you know there's probably a small
number of people who still send me mail
to the wrong company name but after
about six months it was it was done with
the people who know us and they knew
that we were galaxies and we were able
to go forward from there and forget
about trying to incorporate three
different names okay all right so Peter
Peter Seeley you've had a wide variety
of experience with building brands here
I remember that always coca-cola line
isn't it true that we have to pay you
six cents each time we use them I wish I
had a merchandising rights to the polar
bears I'd be you know I would be living
you know in the South of France if I had
that
so you've probably experienced lots of
these different kinds of brands are
there any common pitfalls and brand
building and things that you would warn
people to look out for in this process
of building brands Jim there are many
there's a lot more ways to screw up with
a brand than there is to build one
successfully I'll give you one that most
of the MBAs in this room were just about
being born when it took place and that
was the introduction and massive failure
of New Coke
in this country in 1985 probably the
greatest marketing blunder of the past
probably 3540 years that you I was in
Hollywood I was now I also Hollywood
marketing a film called ishtar at a time
so I Gandhi intensity but I had mine to
a new coke the stuff in that red can
does not taste as good as PepsiCo blind
taste test Pepsi was always had the two
men running coke at that time one was an
Argentinean one was in Mexico mmm they
came up with a new formulation in fact
it was Diet Coke introduced in 1983 a
sugar form that actually began to beat
Pepsi and blind taste test it was you
know happy times in Atlanta because for
the first time they had a product that
looked like it was demonstrably superior
to Pepsi Cola the issue Jim and the
reason Coke was such a and I cannot
describe to you the massive extent of
the failure it was in 30 days the
largest consumer product in the United
States was literally going off the
market place the the outcry there was a
old coke lovers Club people were pouring
new coke down the drains McDonald's was
going crazy
the issue was Jim the coca-cola company
did not have permission to change the
formula of coca-cola or at least to
announce it and put new improved on it
that product was invented by a
pharmacist in Atlanta Georgia in 1886
and it is beloved by people they they
own it more than the coca-cola company
does you can improve a sony dvd you can
improve a BMW 530i
you can't improve an icon you can't
improve Budweiser beer the formulation
recipe has changed but you'll never see
Auguste for putting new better tasting
but a cycle on it and that was probably
an example of where a company literally
misjudges the power it has to change was
a logical decision tasted better trust
me it tasted better still does but the
company did not have permission you have
to understand what the consumer will
give you permission to do I'll give you
a prediction right now another one
Porsche is making a massive mistake with
an SUV Cayenne $78,000 and front-wheel
drive turbocharged v8 4,700 pound
enormous mistake that is not Porsche
when you violate what a brand stands for
as they did with a 928 earlier it will
be a failure
that's why story I'm sticking to it ok
ok so Pete you've had experience in
building brands that are tied to
yourself to your own personality and
image what are some of the challenges
that are associated with building the
personal brand the involving the founder
himself into the brand identification of
the company well when you got a guy this
good-looking it's really what what we
did from day one with the beer was we my
partner and I his name is Mark Brander
we decided that we liked what Ben and
Jerry had done with ice cream with Debby
field did with cookies that that when
there's an identified person people get
behind that person in general so it
turned out with the beer I thought we'd
call it mark and Pete's Brewing Company
repeating Mark's Brewing Company but
just as a side note mark has never had
any alcohol to this day and at the last
minute you decided not to put his name
on it so I said fine we'll call it
Pete's he's regretted that in in in the
course of getting our label out we
actually didn't put a person behind it
other than the name although the role I
took the role I really liked was getting
out there in front of
wholesalers retailers and consumers not
promoting Pete's Brewing far from it but
promoting better beer
the craft beer category my feeling was
if you got the whole tide to rise with
our marketing and sales capability we'd
take more than our fair share and it
wasn't really until like 1996-97 that
our marketing folks decided that it was
important to actually get my mug on the
label just to identify there is a real
person behind it but I think our
foresight in having a real person to be
identified with combined with the fact
that the role I took was not to run a
day-to-day we actually brought in
outside people to run the company and my
partner Scott just took off a little
while ago to go and to go to another
seminar he was the last president of
Pete's growing company and it's one of
the core decisions was not to let our
egos get in the way of doing the right
business decisions and the thing I like
doing was being on the outside not
running day to day so we brought outside
people in in the course of starting the
Chocolate Company what we saw was
successful in the beer company and that
is having the real person identify real
person helped so our bed is with the
chocolate company that we try to do it
the same way now the risk to that is of
course the you know the truck out there
what happens if the truck comes by but
that's that could not always happen but
the reactions so far with the chocolate
company even though we're still in our
infancy is that as wholesalers and
retailers and consumers get to know
there's a real person behind it it
generates a lot more interest and
certainly with the press it's for PR
perspective it's a great great each of
you has been involved in more than one
product category or industry with
respect to branding so I'm gonna ask you
to reflect a little bit on maybe some of
the differences in brand building in one
industry versus another so Pete since
you've been involved in both beer and
chocolate are there any differences or
are there kind of generalizable things
that are this you found that are the
same regardless of the welcome from a
brief exposure about being in the market
about a year and doing a lot of in-store
samplings one of the core differences is
from the consumer perspective is beer
tended to be about two thirds male one
third female talking it tends to be
about just the opposite two thirds
female one
male we made an overt effort in the
course of starting the Chocolate Company
not to identify that I had a
relationship with the beer we sold the
beer company five years ago the brand
has gone in the toilet I was afraid of
being associated with it but what we
found in the last well in the last six
to nine months is when people find out
that I was associated with the beer and
there was a lot of credibility way back
when with the beer they are more tuned
to trying the chocolate product because
they identified that Pete's wicked L had
high quality and then if I created that
creating a chocolate they're willing to
try it more so we're now starting to
identify more with my background being
involved with a beer just because it set
it set a good standard in the beer and
now people expect that we're going to be
brooding a great chocolate and we
deliver on that okay so Peter same
question for you
maybe contrast between the instant
brand-building of movies versus the
long-standing brand tradition of a coke
or can you reflect on any either
differences or similarities many are the
same Jim I mean the the awareness and
image of the brand what it stands for
its promise its personality its attitude
those things are consistent the way
people accept marketing is vastly
different when I was in the wine
business we coke on sterling vineyards
up in Napa Valley
you really can't advertise a premium $30
a bottle Cabernet even if you could
afford to people like to discover
products like that they're they're
unique I think some those of you who
live around here a chain that does a
volume about 50 percent higher than
McDonald's per store does no advertising
is called in-and-out burger it's a it's
a discovered brand people have a
language to talk of Howard Schultz built
Starbucks basic without advertising I
was with Larry Page on Friday at Google
Google's been built without advertising
not a single advert for Google so a coke
has to have advertising so when I
introduced coconut chai nough I had to
advertise coke it wasn't a matter of
always Coca Cola it's a real thing it's
drink Coca Cola cold they didn't
understand that you had to chill the
beverage and
something bad you drink a warm coke it's
not so you've got to understand the
ethos of a brand should you advertise
how much should you advertise I did some
testing at Columbia I actually prove
that I did some matched cities and
increase the ad level of various films
you can advertise a movie too much
people literally think it's becoming
forced on them they that you literally
have a minister with higher advertising
so be careful about what your brand
stands for are you a coca-cola are you a
Google are you a in-and-out burger and
make those decisions of how are you
advertised in a very brand specific way
okay all right now Paul you've been kind
of in one industry so let me ask you
this question cheesecake Andrews cake
all right I mean there are big
differences there I'm not aware of so
what about this and getting started up
is there ever a danger that you would
under spend in creating a brand and it
must be a lot of uses that you could put
that 1 million dollars to that you
raised how do you know how much to
devote and is there ever that kind of
pressure that you won't do it well from
from starting at such a small level and
being the guy who signs the checks it's
it's hard to spend anything on something
intangible and building a brand as
compared to hiring another salesperson
or you know doing something you put your
finger on it
is really scary when when you can see
how quickly you can spend that million
dollars so it's something it's something
we forced ourselves to do and it hurt
every step of the way but you know what
we did is we took we took fifty thousand
dollars and build our tradeshow booth
things like that we did we took a
hundred thousand dollars and spend it on
packaging and packaging development and
creating the logo and all of a sudden
that million dollar starts going to
starts going like that and it's and
there's nothing immediately to
to show that hey that was really it was
a good idea that we did that in
retrospect thank God we did I wish we
had spent a little bit more because I
think the difference between building a
brand in three years and building a
brand in 20 years is how much you can
spend on it you have to spend wisely and
I think we did that to a large extent
but it's you know when you've got
limited resources it's a hard choice
sartruse everybody's asking for it still
and it still is you know even we've got
we've got more money and it's it's still
to do those extra trade shows or to buy
some advertising it's let me ask you
this how would you know the money's
well-spent is there one thing you looked
an objective you set that you could look
back and say this is what we hoped we
would get out of this brand creation I
was in Florida last week and on vacation
and went into a grocery store with my
kids and saw galaxy deserts and went to
the baker manager and asked her about it
she was like oh yeah great and she you
know she she mentioned old brush you
mentioned the lava cake and she
mentioned some some of the things about
the company and you know far away from
home and in a market that we don't get
to all that much that told me that we've
been successful okay I know Hilary one
of the things you've done is you've been
at red envelope and also the W brand one
of the differences was that the W brand
had to be grown out of a kind of a
larger context what were the challenges
associated with building a new brand
inside of an existing brand in an
industry that might have been maybe a
little bit resistant to that yeah that
was I had come to do the W project from
from Pottery Barn I was running product
development design for them and that was
a similar situation and within that
William Sonoma bought Pottery Barn and
the Pottery Barn brands are growing as a
sub brand the difference at W was that
there was not a lot of interest inside
the company about Creedence brand
except for from Barry
who ran the company so they didn't have
a choice and me and I was lucky because
my team was in San Francisco where the
main corporate headquarters was in White
Plains but shortly after I got there as
I said before Weston and Sheridan were
purchased under the Starwood umbrella
and the whole idea of building a concept
like W was really unpopular at and what
I found was that the hotel industry
really didn't like change and so at W
when we started talking about wanting
cotton sheets and wanting down products
and wanting to take that ugly vinyl off
the walls and actually paint the walls
the amount of resistance was enormous
because it was new and it was different
and it had never done been done before
and there was a tremendous concern that
it was going to be too hard for the
hotels to maintain this new look and
feel and I think had W sort of started
from scratch without any of the any of
that history and any of that all those
concerns we would have been able to get
a lot done a lot faster but what I did
learn was that there was a big benefit
in being inside of an industry that
hadn't changed for a long time and it
gotten into a formula because a lot of
the formula had merit we would find that
we would walk down the hallway and our
beautifully painted walls suddenly had
big black scuff marks everywhere which
is what you know vinyl covering doesn't
you don't have that problem and there
was real issues with cotton sheets
weighing down the machines and they had
to get new washing machines and down had
all kinds of maintenance issues with it
so what I learned was being
understanding where the source of the
resistance came from and working in
collaboration with the project managers
and the hotel managers to build a
product that was completely new but
didn't blow up all the infrastructures
that were supporting this business over
many many many years ultimately I think
made W a lot more successful because I
think we would have made a lot of
mistakes had we just you know been
completely out of the box and done
everything
completely new W was really a
collaboration between doing things that
were comfortable for a big brand hotel
with a very innovative point of view in
terms of design and that allowed W to
roll out very quickly so the fact that W
has been able to build so many hotels
very quickly has had a lot to do with
building the basics that really worked
for the hotel business as opposed to
just saying well we're just going to do
it in a new way and that was it was
frustrating but was also I think very
important you've all been played a role
in building brands and thinking about
the challenges associated with building
brands what do you think are some of the
most interesting trends in brand
building what's going on out there who's
doing a great job of building brands and
how are they doing big things happening
now I'll give a speech in LA on Lindsay
that the LA ad Club is the death of
advertisers or supported television as
we know it and it's de munition as a
force in creating brands or even
sustaining existing brands it's
happening and I think to the nba's in
the room you guys are gonna live in a
world where you're gonna do brand
building fundamentally differently than
when yours truly got out of graduate
school at Yale I went to work for the
Procter & Gamble Company that was an era
when America sat down at 9 o'clock at
night 90% of America was tuned to one of
three television channels they did not
have a remote control they were
galvanized they were looking at I mean
gathered around they they had TV dinners
they ate looking at this thing and you
segue from that world to the world of
TiVo where 70% of television viewing is
no longer live and 80% of POD based
commercials are omitted you guys got to
learn how to introduce and market
products without ant support of
television I'll give an example last
year probably the best example of the
product introduction without television
my wife has one is the BMW Mini
automobile
it is unprecedented introduce a new car
in the United States of America without
using television but they did guerrilla
marketing you put a mini on top of the
GM piece GMC Suburban and drove it
around so and the people were galvanized
guerilla marketing they communicated
with people it was just a marvelous
introduction so get ready for the world
of non TV driven brand building and
brand sustained marketing I think
another key trend is the middle class
wants luxury without the trappings of
luxury look at what BMW is doing with
the three class what Mercedes is doing
with their low end class people want
finer goods but they don't want all the
trappings of gold foil and all the other
usual stuff I think that's a key trend
and people wanting better but not being
so hoity-toity so to speak I think it's
I think it's amazing with all the people
in low carb diets how unbelievably
successful Krispy Kreme Doughnuts has
been absolutely amazing you know other
extreme and people people it's such a
hot brand you see terrible companies
like Albertsons trying to use Krispy
Kreme Doughnuts to improve their brand
and obviously very narrowly focused but
I think that's an awesome brand and the
great can you explain how you think they
have overcome what should be this
underlying trend of resistance against
well they've generate and I don't know
how I honestly have no idea how they
generated such tremendous buzz I mean
they're you know they've got the buzz
they've got the hot you know the hot
thing they also you know they also have
a little bit of I think the
entertainment factor you see that in in
popular and successful restaurant chains
now too it's not just not just eating
it's the experience and for the Krispy
Kreme Doughnuts you know you're not just
getting you know just getting a normal
doughnut you're getting a little bit of
theater and you're getting experience
there's a lot of good stuff here I want
to add I think that interesting things
with brand is is how radically
everything's changing Peter talked about
television advertising going away
we're seeing in specialty retail that
especially retailers that have lots of
stores are being blown away by how many
of them customers are moving to the web
and they're suddenly worried about where
they're going to do with all its
expensive real estate that they've
invested in that's a huge shift and it's
happening I mean you talk to companies
they can't believe how many their
customers are moving to the web without
any incentive so the markets are
shifting there is a huge interest in
honest simple brands like Krispy Kreme
there is amazing things happening in the
luxury sector I mean people you know
Gucci got taken over Burberry got taken
over coach got taken over there are some
of the most exciting brands happening
right now and they're old stodgy luxury
brands that have just been completely
reinvented so everywhere you look in all
sectors there's a tremendous amount of
change and one small catalyst creates an
enormous Ripple @w you know we now have
Marriott worrying about their polyester
comforters because they're doing down
comforters and they're I mean the whole
hotel industry the major big brands are
completely changing so small you know
small catalysts are creating enormous
change across industries which i think
is really interesting to see just the
pace of change and how many brands are
evolving and how much the market is
moving Jim there's a bifurcation going
on you'll see people having a you know a
400 calorie galaxy dessert and making up
for that by drinking diet coke you'll
see people going to spend Ronna cos are
our draggers and paying you know from
top-of-the-line stuff and also pushing a
big metal cart at Costco and buying
bathroom tissue in 24 pack rolls with a
Mercedes s500 outside an interesting
mixture
to gala tea and lodges and lig so yeah
it's it's not a world you can say you
know I'm just gonna have a spin it used
to be a single solution it's not anymore
you
can use can you sell a c-class Mercedes
for $29,000 and an S 600 AMG for
$135,000 in the same dealership they are
fundamentally different automobiles and
I I don't know how far you can stretch
BMWs introducing a 2 class 2 Series BMW
a and looking at a 1 Series so you have
seven five you know three two one
I don't think you can stretch that puppy
that far it against to be what the hell
do you stand for is a brand
yeah for us it's a word-of-mouth
discovery it's the only way to go
Americans don't buy into advertising in
general now so it's they trust their
friends when their friends tell them I
found something good so we did with the
beer was a lot of beer tastings a lot of
unique things to generate word-of-mouth
and they're applying the same principles
to getting the chocolate out there yeah
absolutely we spend we spend money on PR
for that reason you know if someone can
write a story about it about us the
third person and get our message across
people will believe that and they won't
believe any type of advertising so we
actively try to do that
I think you know when we looked at when
we built the red envelope brand we
thought deeply about the gift-giving
experience in America and what's
interesting when you look at it
Americans are terrible gift givers and
there's we have so much pressure and
obligation that we've piled on top of
ourselves and we have all these Hallmark
holidays and you know god help you don't
get the right gift of your mom and then
you have to get some other good
Valentine's Day we have all this
pressure and so for the giver and the
recipient there's not enough joy and
spontaneity in the process and when you
look around the world gift-giving is
much more what you'd want it to be
because it's a spontaneous gesture they
don't have all these holidays that
create all this anxiety so what we focus
on I mean I think you know we talked
about building brands and I and I truly
believe that the innovation of your
product and really addressing a customer
need the way nobody else is will build
your business faster than any piece of
advertising you could do and it red
envelope all of our products we design
ourselves and we think a lot about the
gift game experience we worry about
what's a good sympathy gift you cannot
buy a sympathy gift out there and it's
important for people what does a
Mother's Day gift should it be I mean if
you look at most Mother's Day gifts
they've got moms trapped in this
outdated idea of what a mother was in
the 1950s now so what does a modern
mother really want her gift and we
create those gifts because the market
really is out of step
partly because gift gifting is not a big
focus for most companies and so I think
what brings people back is the fact that
we're really really relevant for them
and the gifts that we offer and then
they're not gifts that you can buy
anywhere else and that they serve the
modern Americans needs in in what they
want for for gifts for people
I would say the best in your industry
the best example of doing that really
well is Patagonia I mean it's it built
as the top-of-the-line sporting
equipment that was the most expensive
you can buy but there's nothing
alienating about that brand it's the
most welcoming brand and they've done
incredibly well because their product
once you wear their product there's no
going back and so I think that it can be
done but I think Pete talked about the
trappings of luxury brands and I think
those are very damaging to a brand
because you don't want people to feel
like they don't have access to your
brand if they're really rich or they
look a certain way you know and we we I
know it W really tried hard to avoid the
problem the previous says because you
know Ian Schrager 's brand was came out
of the studio 54 which is you know
lining up for club and the bouncer would
look at you and decide if you were hip
enough to get in people don't want that
you know if they don't they want to feel
like they can if they love a brand they
can access a brand that can be
comfortable there I don't you to think
about I think a brand has three things
that's a positioning what it stands for
it has a personality they're kind of
what it what it what it looks like to
you it also has an attitude an attitude
about a brand is what you think the
brand thinks about you and most people
don't think to that level brands have
attitudes and if you have a brand I know
certain brands exclude me I really feel
they did forget about the rationale
economics and so give some consideration
to that as to what what it what are you
projecting in that in that case in terms
of the attitude of your brand towards
the customer
we never own manufacturing capability it
was a core principle of our beer company
in our chocolate company from day one it
was outsourced two things about
outsourcing number one is it frees up
capital for sales and marketing which is
important to us
number two the quality controls of an
outsourced partner are going to be far
and away ten times 20 times 100 times
superior to what you can afford in a
small company so we had much better
quality of our product we had much
better ability to ramp up production and
we could use the freedom resources for
sales and marketing a lot of other
people in the craft beer industry kind
of pointed us and say you're not a real
Brewer your contract brewing and really
the only people did that were other
Brewers who have to have their own deal
with it having their own factories that
we never have contract manufacturing as
a real issue with consumers they were
interested in your product and will you
present the product
I'm a proponent of global branding I
mean I feel strongly that to be the case
where companies that do not do that
Procter & Gamble I think really only has
about two global brands having shoulders
one tide is not sold in Europe I think
as we become more and more globalized
you get more and more homogenized I can
recall Bob wading had a marketing of
Procter & Gamble's selling head and
shoulders in in Arabic countries where
the men have head dresses on and he had
to show them the dandruff was just
itching us he couldn't show dandruff
because they in those things I had a
commercial on coke always a dog digging
a bone out of the ground and I couldn't
show that commercial in Islamic
countries you adapt but the benefits of
if you've got a consistent product
around the world benefits of a global
brand or tremendous I believe just being
a small company the thought of a global
brand we're trying to make a northern
California success and if we think about
anything outside of the country it's a
waste of time
I look at it I think you have some of
some trust marks that float over
Starwood to me as a trust mark it sits
over the Luxury Collection share them
the Westin W so on the Ford Motor
Company is a trust mark a master brand
that sits on top of Aston Martin Jaguar
Volvo Ford Mercury Lincoln and I think
the best companies have that you know I
someone spending two hundred forty
thousand dollars for an Aston Martin I
think they kind of are happy that that's
a car of the Ford Motor Company because
they only make a few thousand of them a
year so I think you can have a quatrain
gamble does that I mean it's that trust
mark Sears you've Craftsman tools that
it's a part of Sears when you do those
two in combination a trust mark and a
brand specific product mark I think
that's the best combination we're having
that internal discussion right now
because in launching our low-carb line
we're it's already so big and were
expected to be so big we're giving it
its own its own brand name they're
called dream cakes so we're going
through the whole process of creating
creative and image for that and we're
split as to whether we should be doing
it because it's hard enough building one
brand and we almost feel like we're
building a second brand so I'm not sure
we're doing the right thing we'll see
we knew that our bet was that craft
beers would take off we were early we
thought it would the whole segment would
take off in that and if you go down a
beer aisle there may have been a hundred
beers in 1986 when we started we viewed
that as two to three to four hundred
beers you know five to ten years out as
as we expected the whole segment to grow
what does the consumer do when they go
down the aisle their eyes flip back and
forth they look for colors that look for
shapes they look for names and it was
one of the core one of the key first
decisions we had to make was what is the
name besides personalizing it what
adjectives we were going to use and we
were lucky we heard a community not in a
San Francisco radio station used wicked
and we liked it but what happened was
over time when I'd ask people are on the
country you wanted to try Pete's wicked
ale with the electric and I like to try
it for the first time and they
ninety-nine hundred people told me when
they saw the name wicked they had to try
it
I think names are interesting when I was
at Pottery Barn that was a huge debate
because Pottery Barn and Crate and
Barrel actually grew up side-by-side in
the 50s in fact the two companies were
very interlinked and cratenbarrel they
literally put their product on crates
and barrels that's where the name came
from Pottery Barn was literally pottery
in stores look like barn so I was called
Pottery Barn and so as the two companies
grew we started becoming furniture
companies that had nothing to do with
pottery and Crate and Barrel didn't have
anything with crates and barrels anymore
although actually they still have crates
in their stores just for fun but there
was lots of debate about Banana Republic
was having the same debate at the same
time around okay now we have nothing to
do with Banana Republic
you know clothing those brands stood for
the product and the name almost didn't
matter I mean you know when you think
about Pottery Barn you don't think about
pottery Barn's anymore
however there Ken names can be negative
I had that situation with red envelope
because our original aim was nine
hundred guess calm and talk about a
debate that was such a debate because it
was considered to be the perfect calm
name because in those days you always
did a number because the number of rows
tops on the search engines you always
had to say exactly what you did I know
if you remember
days but it was garden calm toys calm
you know everyone you know so it was a
perfect name as far as comms were
considered cuz it started with the
number so just rose to the search
engines and it had yes it was a terrible
name from from a consumer perspective
because it had so many negative
connotations and this was before
September 11 so you can imagine what
would happen if we kept the name and we
had big debates about that name being
negative enough that it was going to be
a barrier for that company to grow but
when we changed the name to red envelope
there was a lot of criticism that what
does that mean no one knows what that
means I think if you're in a in the
position to be able to start a company
thinking about the name it's a really
nice place to be
the issue though is I believe you don't
want a name to trap you too much Pottery
Barn is a perfect example
you know the Maine worked really well
and they were selling pottery and barns
but it didn't work well as they evolved
as a business and so I think names can
be limiters sometimes but often if if
the product and the brand what you stand
for is great in most cases it doesn't
really matter what the name of the
company I think judge mean you got a
great name is when the consumer takes it
on and modifies it it took Fred Smith on
how many years to rename the company
FedEx cope was not created by the
coca-cola copy was created by consumers
Mickey D's for McDonald's has came out
of the kids when people do that then boy
go with it I mean you know you've that's
that's when they take they have an
affection for it and beyond the the just
the trademark you've got a logo you've
got a shape you've got a symbol is it
Colonel Sanders is it the Mercedes star
is it when I rent a car I'm going down
the escalator I look for the gold I mean
because I know that's hurt a sound like
Intel Inside you've got to surround
those just the brand with those other
trappings that people begin to identify
the contour shape for coca-cola is a
trademark you know incredible value so
not only just the name itself but the
trappings of that Ed Koch I wouldn't it
greet new employees with a sign in back
of me he'll I'll greet them every every
and at a big coca-cola logo I misspelled
coca-cola delivered coca-cola 20 years
no one ever said excuse me mr. Seeley
you made a typo out there on the night
because they weren't looking at eight
letters they were looking at a visual
image literally did not could not see a
typo that's a brand that has entered the
consumers psyche you know in a more
fundamental ways it's beyond the letters
of the English language that's what you
want to go for it's it's a huge issue I
mean talk about talk about a limiting
brand I bought a company called the
cheesecake lady so that was me for a
while so so so having the opportunity
when we when we put the merger together
to come up with a new company name was
grams it was liberating
to convince Eric and Larry and Sergei
that there are now about to enter a
marketing battle Google now Terry Semel
announced last week Yahoo is dropping
Google as their search engine it is a
matter of time till hey oh well does the
same the evil empire in the north
you know gates has got the engineers
that work on it it's going to be a
tremendous battle now and I think
becoming a branding and marketing battle
so respectfully I would tell them get
ready because I'll guarantee it's now
going to escalate beyond just the pure
superiority of the product you cannot
maintain product superiority long term
in a technology area in the modern world
I'd go with a descriptive brand at that
point bang roto-rooter I mean it kind of
says what it you know in those low
interest categories these guys are lucky
YouTube your uncle your current company
people will write about your company
they're people who write about beers
tastings and and desserts when you're in
a category people don't write about
plumbing services I mean there's no
magazine covering you know new
developments and clearing out drain
pipes you know what you don't have those
you know you don't have that ability to
use public relations and other people
right you've got to have a name and a
focus that just literally signals what
you do I think I think you can also
really build a brand within your trade
whatever the trade is so the people in
your trade know whatever it is you want
them to know whether it's your the
faster your the cheapest but that's a
good way to get the name out there I do
it you can do it through trade shows do
it through agreements with the right
people education it's a lot of time in
the pavement but it's it's it's almost
it's almost guerrilla branding to not to
the end consumer but to the people who
are gonna refer you or refer the
customers AdWords search on Google I
mean there's a case where somebody's got
you know stopped-up pipes and on Google
and boom you can buy your way up to the
first listing it's you want to pay a
buck they'll give you the first listing
I think the closest I've come to
thinking about that kind of business
that doesn't isn't sexy as you said is
um
in a funny way the what web man did when
it was still alive and it was you know
they had these fans that you would
notice they painted these great colors
the web and guys that would come in were
like incredibly friendly and they had
these big tubs that were really
recognizable and I think there's a lot
of tools in those industries that can
catch attention because you're in
neighborhoods and have a personality
that's really distinctive and becomes
the brand that really could
differentiate your company or any
company from
companies that may not have the same
brand sex appeal but has its own ability
to brand itself
not only you're introducing a brand
every couple of weeks you don't know how
good your competition is I mean at least
when you were designing W you knew your
competition you introduced a product
into the existing market place it's
dependent upon the film itself
I remember one with Richard Pryor it was
called Jo Jo dancer your life is calling
it was a terrible story he made us made
of his life it was he was into cocaine
of scenes of him getting granules of
cocaine off the floor it was a
depressing ugly movie and I had my
marketing director sell it as a comedy
they were like three smiles in the movie
and she cut the trailer to that I did
another movie called stand by me written
by Richard Steven King about four young
boys going to find a dead body none of
the boys at that time were well known we
couldn't tell people even was written by
Stephen King we sold it it was an
evocative kind of you know what's my
favorite product Pez cherry flavored Pez
it was a kind of a symbolic sell so
sometimes you sell away from the movie
sometimes you sell a star sometimes if
you got a sequel you've got it built in
it's a good thing you didn't sell the
blueberry pie eating contest by the way
I have Bob Lackey who runs marketing at
anheuser-busch coming to marketing 392 I
want to have him explain to the class
how he had a flat on the course on the
Superbowl and actually made a commercial
out of that for a beverage profit
I can't remember the rear up III
remember brainstorming and we tend we
must have tested it with at most 25
people and everybody liked it so we went
with it I have no idea what the
runner-up was in our case we were
essentially peers talking about it's
about the name and the logo I have a
thing where I can't stand logos I just
think it's like one more people have
like the name and the logo and it's so
busy so I said to Barry can we just not
have a logo he said no that you know not
in the hotel industry that's a level
logo so it came one day so I've got a
great idea come up with a name it's also
a logo I want to call it the W and it
was just one of those things where I
said that's perfect because it fixed the
problem the W is the name and the logo
and you were talking about you know
brands that have affection people call
it the W I mean they have an affection
for the way they think so it worked at
red envelope we said we wanted to have a
name that had to do with gift-giving but
that was mysterious and that you know
there was something that was something
meaningful about gifts so we all it was
just a group of people in the company
actually we had a naming company that
was a disaster
sometimes that works did not work for us
and our head of merchandising was a
woman who would escape with her family
from Vietnam and she told us a story
about the red envelope and the Asian
tradition of the red envelope and you
you have I mean there was 20 people in
the room people were practically in
tears I mean she told the story in such
a beautiful way that we just said that's
us that that's our name what was
interesting in that time was then we had
a fight for the name because every name
was taken I don't remember that so you
know but what we fell in love with the
name the hard part was actually getting
the name and you know being able to use
it
I don't think there's a great
distinction I mean I you know your your
the hotel industry is assisting a
service industry you still have what you
stand for what your promises I mean it's
daunting it is not distinctly different
than a physical product you know I think
of you know I I just look there's any
difference really anybody else are you
know I did any any ex Bain employees
here mm-hmm I worked for bein back in
the in the mid 80s when it was young and
service company but there was there was
definitely an attitude behind the Bain
brand and that's that's what we pushed
and got reinforced we had to watch
videos so we understood what you know
what the what the brand meant and what
the company was all about in service
companies the people become the product
and so that's you know a big part of
what you're selling as your brand is the
people that are providing the service
become your product yeah and I think
that's true for any company I mean in
order to get a brand to really come to
life every single employee has to as
they say live the brand and really have
it in their heart and soul well what we
found with the chocolate doing a lot of
in-store samplings is people of all ages
love the chocolate but there's a
fundamental
the audience is going for us one of my
lectures
if I was coming off as John Costello who
runs marketing for the Home Depot and I
think John will tell you head of
marketing at Sears also introduce softer
side of Sears he will tell you that you
know Lowe's over the last few years
really has outperformed the Home Depot
in terms of that in-store service that
friendliness it was a time when a Home
Depot employee would chase you out to
the parking lot telling you how to
install a faucet and I think they lost
some of that and I think John will
probably talked when he comes here about
how he has to reinstall that into that
that to her point it's absolutely that
experience in that store the attitude of
those people with the orange apron how
do they treat you that is the
personality of the Home Depot and if you
lose that somebody will really come up
behind you and make games Southwest
Airlines is probably an example for
example yeah they do the same thing
I think I think it's really important I
think it's definitely increasing we we
do a lot of Cadillac shopping we wear
one of the largest drop shippers from
williams-sonoma and Neiman Marcus
maybe someday red envelope and we
switched away from styrofoam a couple
years ago to a new product on air liner
which is environment which takes up
maybe one percent of the space of
styrofoam when we ship and it's a huge
selling point when we go talk to you
know where we're dealing with Starbucks
right now and they have a whole
packaging department you know we're
looking for biodegradable plastics to
use instead of our regular plastic
packages but when they found out that we
use the airline of that oh you're the
kind of company what we want to work
with we were on when we were on food
fines from the Food Network showing
again March 26 9 p.m. we spent we showed
them even though I had nothing to do
with making cakes we showed them the
package so and that was that was
actually part of the you know part part
of what made it on the air so I think
it's huge I think I like Fairtrade
coffee
dolphin-safe tuna sometimes it becomes a
literally a an imperative you either are
in it Procter and Gamble is even looking
in the coffee side that being able to
say look this is coffee that's purchased
and grown under under sustainable and
and proper conditions so I think it's
look at what happens when when people
get in trouble with with sweatshops on
clothing outside this country Kathie Lee
Gifford I think of you years ago or
insider trading insider trading well we
have me at a point in our product
listing our ingredient list any any word
we won't use any ingredient that has
three syllables or more except for
chocolate
like the internet is going to be
incredibly powerful we are just
beginning to get this country broadband
wired
we're pathetically behind the nation of
South Korea is it got the most broadband
wired households in the world and it's
like 20 megabits that's not a paltry you
know one and a half two it opens up a
whole new world with streaming video of
an ability to really Insadong on
wireless networks in your home yeah well
you know I think the best example is is
is Adwords a Google where the
advertising is directly related to you
know wastage type in Miami vacation boom
it's related to you
addressable media again you guys in the
audience here we're going to have a
digital pipeline into the home soon
that's going to have your
telecommunications your voice
communications internet film
entertainment music whole things that
come in with with zeros and ones one big
pipe I don't who's gonna on the pipe but
in within that pipe we're gonna be able
to insert commercials and really make
those commercials on the fly designed
for you if you've got a child under 12
months in the home you're getting
kimberly-clark Huggies commercials if
you don't you're not my favorite is the
the C bond dental adhesive they buy news
programs trying to reach people with no
teeth I don't know how many people
without teeth about watching the news
programs but that I gotta believe what
is it 98 percent wastage of people that
don't need dental adhesive that kind of
advertising is just
it can't sustain itself and what we're
gonna have with the internet I think and
permission marketing is a communication
and dialogue I'm gonna I'm going to talk
about this dessert line I'm gonna have
people who want to know about it and who
are gonna get involved and I'm gonna you
know communicate with them and that's
where advertising is going and where
umpa students are going to spend your
marketing life your advertising not
women 18 to 34 one-to-one marketing to
the individual level we also see that we
have some fanatics out there over our
products and and through the internet
they can either on their own websites or
contact through their own lists get the
word out so I think from an advocate
advocacy the internet will be great for
just spreading the word